driving into hawara now feels like
you're approaching the front line of a
wall every time I've been here the High
Street has been busy with people but now
the metal shutters are down and almost
every shop is closed
the town is teeming with Israeli
Soldiers the IDF has deployed more units
to the West Bank in an effort to calm
the tensions
but they're not welcome here
[Music]
hi Sophia
look at these flashbangs and smoke
grenades Sultan fruit tells me he points
out the Hebrew writing on them they were
fired towards our house by the soldiers
why we had children inside and we were
the ones being attacked
the car yard he owns is next door I
count 79 burnt wrecks
the riot started after two young
Israelis were shot dead by a Palestinian
whilst driving through the town on
Sunday
this CCTV shows masked settlers piling
wooden pallets in front of a door and
setting fire to them they carry on for
four minutes the IDF was nearby but no
one stops them
Noel was alone inside the fire knocked
out her electricity water and internet
so she couldn't call anyone for help
she stayed here alone for 24 hours
without everything because no
electricity every eating in the fridge
was lost she stayed alone here without
anything
it's all of this balcony was smashed
these are the rocks that were thrown
and when Noel came to put the fire out
to the front door to pour water over the
balcony
she tells me that the Israeli military
fired stun grenades gas canisters up so
she had to retreat back into her home
and the fire was still burning
downstairs
the Rampages caused outrage across the
world that yesterday one of the most
senior Israeli government ministers
bezel smotrich the far-right Finance
Minister said that hawara should be
wiped out we are going to the third in
tifada this is the final intifada the
predictions of a new interfada are
becoming more common and with factions
on both sides seemingly unwilling to
back down
it's hard to see how this gets any
better
Alistair Buckle Sky News in hawara